- The biggest thing that's
tough when you're young
is reconciling two things.
Reconciling why you see it so clearly,
and not just saying we're young.
And two, understanding
what happens over time.
(light rock music)
(light music)
What up, vlog, finally back in New York.
Haven't been here in
four weeks, feels like
some more renovations at the city arts.
And uh, full day of meetings,
good to be back in NYC.
Gloomy as shit, but let's get into it.
(music continues)
You guys can come in.
This is a secret wine meeting.
(hands slap)
- Happy new year, brother.
- You too, bro.
- How you doin', man?
- I'm really, really well.
- What's up, man?
Mike Grabel.
- Did you play during the
time that it was in the,
did you ever play in the Olympics?
- No, that was 1904, 1908.
- Oh, seriously, that's--
- That long ago, yeah.
Lacrosse is, there's so--
- Oh, I--
- many good stories to
tell about lacrosse, it's
the oldest game in North America, played
by the indigenous, Native American people.
- No I know, I've seen,
like, picture-- like I, every
time I think about, like how--yeah, 100%.
- Textbooks and everything.
- Yeah, that's what gets us really excited
is the storytelling.
- Well, that's the, I mean,
I'm obsessed with that shit.
- That's right.
- And do you play in the
World Games, in your career?
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Man] Coming up.
- This is my third time.
- And how has America done?
- Well, yeah.
We've won one and we've
lost one, we beat Canada
my first time around and lost to Canada
my second time around, so.
- And those have been the only two?
- U.S.-Canada, uh, that I've played in.
Now the World Games have stretched back to
probably like the early 70s?
- Early 70s?
- So the U.S. typically
dominates, as the sport's grown.
In '99 there were nine
countries sanctioned to play,
now there are over 60, and
in the 2014 games, four years
before this, they uh, USOC
and IOC were there, because we
hit all the check boxes
that were required to submit
an application to be an Olympic sport.
And a lot that's around like
by global participation.
And they're gonna create
actually, we think some new rules
around the sport to make it,
uh kind of gender agnostic,
which is important for the
Olympics, they're gonna
probably make it like
kind of a global language
in the way of rules, which
you call, like a shot clock--
grab some of the nuances, anyway.
We're moving in the direction
of where we think the
sport will go at the Olympics,
because it's just such
a big opportunity, really
opens up the game globally.
- So the stage is set for 2028, um--
- In L.A.
- In L.A., for lacrosse
to be played there.
And that's what they're all working on.
- The World Games to be hosted in L.A.?
- No, just the Olympics.
- [Man] So lacrosse will be in
the Olympics, yeah, in 2028.
- [Man] Yeah.
- So that's kind of a North Star of sorts.
It's a fun year to put out
there of like, what happens
between right this second,
and 2028, regardless of like,
Look, I think the Olympics
equity is diluting
at a rapid pace?
- [Man] Yeah.
- So like, but I think it's
still a good arbitrary number
to like, play within, right?
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Man] Yeah, so we talk at a macro level.
- I think the Olympic ratings
on this one coming up,
- [Man] Gonna crush--
- Are going to be a disaster.
- [Man] Hmm.
- [Man] From viewership?
- Yes.
- [Man] Yeah, huh.
- [Man] Because linear, or?
- Because I don't think
anybody gives a fuck.
- [Man] Hm.
- Do you give a fuck?
(laughter)
That's the best thing that ever happened.
- [Man] Everything, everything.
- Respect, respect.
- [Man] Everything.
- That was the worst moment of my career.
The worst moment of my career.
(music: Mm Mm Mm)
When I'm walking the
floor it's good to get the
grandness of, like, what's
going on it, you know?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Like how many different
people, you know?
Hey, Linda, how are you?
- [Linda] Hey.
- Are you following me?
- No, I'm kinda just walking
the floor a little bit.
What's up, Zenk?
- How's it goin'?
- Hey, Joe Q.
- Hey, what's goin' on?
- Hey, how are you?
- Vee.
- What up, Blue?
Buyin' some krypto.
How you doin,' bro?
- It's good to see you,
man, I haven't seen, I like,
I feel like we've talked, and
I haven't seen you in so long.
- This is my business partner--
- I know him.
- Other is Xander.
- Hey, man, how are you?
- Met you, with, uh--
- Yeah, I remember, uh--
- [Xander] Xander.
- How do you spell it?
- [Xander] X-A-N-
- Oh, like Milo guy.
- Xander actually watched your--
when did you watch Gary, dude?
- [Man] Um... couple years.
- He showed me you, so he watched you...
- Thanks, brother.
- Three years ago, four years ago.
- 'S awesome, 's awesome.
- The biggest thing that's
tough when you're young
is reconciling two things.
Reconciling why you see it so clearly,
and not just saying we're young.
And two, understanding
what happens over time.
What gets commoditized.
Your knowledge gets commoditized.
More people will know, people
are starting to understand.
Like when GaryVee, on the back
of not Entrepreneur Magazine,
or the planet of the apps show
I did that nobody watched,
but on the back of
Instagram, and--thank you--
(laughter)
Instagram, and, and, um--
- [Man] Got it on all the--
- And YouTube, you know,
like yeah, like that stuff,
like that stuff is everything.
It's trading culture.
The thing that you guys have
to decide as a partnership,
is what you-- this is the best advice:
the two of you need to start
getting unbelievably real
with each other about how
you care about the next 12
days, 12 weeks, 12 months and 12 years.
Because that's the only
thing that matters.
Both of you are holding certain
things back, as you should,
it's human nature.
- [Man] Not me!
(laughs)
- But, no, no, you know
what subconscious bias is?
- Yeah.
- [GaryVee] That's what you're, that's
what we all do, we all--
- I'm kinda nuts, though.
- [GaryVee] Respect,
but no humans, me, too!
But guess what, but
there's still other stuff.
- Yeah.
- And it's about anticipation.
What happens if you fall in
love with a crazy person?
What happens if your mother gets sick?
Like, I'm talking everything,
not like, how good you
wanna feel transparently.
- [Man] Mm hmm.
- Like I wanna screw him.
Most people don't wanna screw people.
- No, I hear what you mean.
- [GaryVee] It's a--
- Really, really delve into,
um, hooks and crannies.
- [GaryVee] Of Course!
- Thank you man, I really
appreciate it, seriously.
- It's really good to see you, bro.
- Thank you.
- Oh, lemme take a picture.
Oh, actually--
- [Man] Dave, we're gonna--
- Wait a minute, you
got my, wait a minute!
This is the advantage you
have: my daughter watches
this shit, I gotta get something good.
- What's her name, Michy?
- Misha, ready?
- What's up, Misha!
I'm here, we're hanging out with your dad.
Convince him to come
down to L.A., we'll get
a set tour, and we'll hang out.
- I promise, Mish.
- Oh, damn!
- Ah, you just made a promise!
- I will deliver on it.
All right, let's take a photo.
(music: Mm Mm Mm)
See you guys, see you,
vlog, good day, see ya, bye.
music: Mm Mm Mm